CANDIDATE HIDING DAILY IN A
BASEMENT.
IF JOE CAN’T CAMPAIGN, HOW DO
YOU TRUST HIM TO BE PRESIDENT?
HERE WITH REACTION FROM THE
TRUMP ORGANIZATION, ERIC TRUMP
IS WITH US.
OKAY, YOUR DAD IS OUT THERE.
NOT LIKE THEY’RE GOING TO GIVE
JOE HARD QUESTIONS LIKE THEY DID
THE PUBLIC PRESS CONFERENCES,
WHO DO I GO NEXT TO?
DAVID FROM NBC.
I MEAN SOMETHING IS AUDIT.
OKAY, HOW DO YOU BECOME
PRESIDENT WHEN YOU WON’T TALK,
WHEN YOU WON’T SHOW UP, WHEN YOU
WON’T TAKE QUESTIONS, WHEN YOU
DON’T GET HARD QUESTIONS?
>> THE BAR IS SO LOW, ALL DAY
YESTERDAY HAD TRAVELED THROUGH
THE WHOLE STATE AND THE
ENTHUSIASM THERE IS INCREDIBLE.
MY FATHER WAS THERE THE DAY
BEFORE, THE VICE PRESIDENT IS
THERE TODAY, IT’S BEEN 660 DAYS
SINCE BIDEN HAS BEEN IN
WISCONSIN.
HE WAS SUPPOSED TO HAVE THE DNC
IN MILWAUKEE.
IT’S BEEN 660 DAYS SINCE HE’S
BEEN THERE AND NO ONE ASKS THE
QUESTION, WHY HASN’T BIDEN
SHOWED UP?
THE SAME THING WITH MICHIGAN AND
ALL THESE -- THE MEDIA SETS THE
BAR SO LOW.
IF MY FATHER DIDN’T GO TO A
BATTLEGROUND STATE FOR 660 DAYS,
THEY’D BE ON TOP OF HIM, THEY
WOULD BE GOING CRAZY.
HE DIDN’T EVEN SHOW UP IN THE
STATE THAT THE DNC WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE AT, HE HASN’T BEEN THERE
FOR TWO PLUS YEARS AND EVERYBODY
GIVES HIM A PASS.
THEY’VE SET THE BAR SO LOW, ALL
HE HAS TO DO IS LIVE THROUGH THE
INTERVIEWS OR THE SPEECH
TOMORROW.
SO LONG AS HE’S STILL LIVING AT
THE END OF THE THING THEY’RE
GOING TO APPLAUDED AS BEING THE
GREATEST PIECE OF LINGUAL ART
THAT’S EVER HAPPENED.
IT’S CRAZY, THE BAR IS SO LOW,
IT’S DISGUSTING.
>> Sean: THE BAR IS LOW.
I WOULD BET EVERYTHING I HAVE
THAT IS BEEN PRACTICING,
PRACTICING, PRACTICING.
LOOK AT THE POLL I TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER HERE.
THERE ARE MORE AMERICANS,
MAJORITY HALF OF DEMOCRATS
BELIEVE BIDEN WILL NOT FINISH A
FOUR-YEAR TERM.
IT FOR ALL THE QUESTIONS THE MOB
AND THE MEDIA ASKED ABOUT REAGAN
IN 1984, JOE BIDEN WILL BE OLDER
AND HIS FIRST DAY OF OFFICE AND
REAGAN WAS ON HIS LAST DAY OF
OFFICE.
>> I THINK THAT’S WHY THEY
ENCOURAGED A RADICAL TO RUN WITH
HIM.
YOU DID A BEAUTIFUL JOB COVERING
THE OPENING BUT GETTING RID OF
ALL PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE,
180 MILLION PEOPLE, OVER HALF
THE PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY WOULD
LOSE PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS.
FREE HEALTH CARE FOR EVERY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT, DEFUNDING
POLICE.
THEY TRIED TO DO THAT IN
NEW YORK, THEY GOT RID OF ALL
UNDERCOVER POLICE OFFICERS IN
NEW YORK AND CRIME WENT UP BY
250% IN THREE MONTHS.
IT DOESN’T WORK.
THE POINT YOU’RE MAKING IS
EXACTLY RIGHT, THEY WANTED
SOMEBODY WHO IS AN ABSOLUTE
LEFT-WING RADICAL BECAUSE EVEN
IF JOE BIDEN WAS IN OFFICE DO
YOU THINK HE’S GOING TO BE
RUNNING GOVERNMENT?
THE GUY CALLED ARIZONA A CITY
LAST NIGHT.
HE SAID HE WAS RUNNING FOR
SENATOR OF THE UNITED STATES.
HE’S RUNNING FOR
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF AND ARIZONA
IS A GREAT STATE, YOU THINK THIS
GUY HAS THE APTITUDE TO RUN
GOVERNMENT?
COME ON, LET’S CALL A SPADE A
SPADE.
>> Sean: LET’S LOOK AT KAMALA
HARRIS, SHE HAS A MORE LEFTIST,
SOCIALIST RECORD IN THE U.S.
SENATE IN 2019 THAN BOLSHEVIK
BURNING HIMSELF.
SHE FEELS IT’S THE RIGHT OF A
PRESIDENT TO JUST BYPASS THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT, TAKE AWAY PEOPLE’S
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS, THAT’S
PRETTY LOT OF FALL, SHE WILL
ELIMINATE FRACKING, SPONSORED
THE RADICAL NEW GREEN DEAL IN
THE U.S. SENATE, $94 TRILLION.
I DON’T THINK YOU NEED TO
GRADUATE FROM HARVARD OR MIT TO
FIGURE OUT WHEN YOU’RE ONLY
TAKING FOUR AND A HALF TRILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR THAT THE 94 IN
TEN YEARS WILL BANKRUPT THE
COUNTRY.
HOW IS ENDING FRACKING AND
ELIMINATING ALL FOSSIL FUELS
GOING TO FLY IN PENNSYLVANIA AND
WISCONSIN AND OHIO AND
MIDWESTERN STATES WHERE YOUR DAD
TO BRING THE JOBS BACK?
>> THE FACT THAT WE ARE FRACKING
IS THE REASON WE HAVE $2
GASOLINE RIGHT NOW, THE REASON
IT COSTS SO LITTLE TO HEAT OUR
HOMES ON A RELATIVE BASIS
ACCORDING TO SEVEN YEARS AGO
BECAUSE MY FATHER MADE THIS
COUNTRY ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
ONE OTHER THING THAT NO ONE IS
BRINGING UP AND I DON’T KNOW
WHY, SHE’S FROM SAN FRANCISCO,
BEAUTIFUL CITY.
UNFORTUNATELYUNFORTUNATELY, IT’S
ABSOLUTE HELL, SEAN.
LOOK AT THE CRIME IN THAT CITY,
THE HOMELESSNESS IN THAT CITY,
YOU WALK YOUR KIDS TO SCHOOL AND
YOU ARE WALKING OVER HYPODERMIC
NEEDLES AND THIS IS A CITY YOU
GOVERNED OVER.
IF YOU WANT TO TO THE REST OF TH
COUNTRY, ALL THE SWING STATES
AND THE REST OF THE COUNTRY TO
EMULATE SAN FRANCISCO AND THE
POLICIES, YOU KNOW, AGAIN, IF
YOU WANT, SHE’S THE PERFECT
RUNNING MATE FOR YOU.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE DNC AS THEY
ARE TONE-DEAF TO THESE ISSUES
AND WHAT THEIR PARTY STANDS FOR
AND HOW RADICAL IT IS AND HOW
DISCONNECTED IT IS.
IT MIGHT WORK IN NEW YORK CITY
AND MIGHT WORK IN LOS ANGELES
BUT IT DOESN’T WORK IN THE OTHER
STATES AND THEY LOSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND I THINK YOU SEE THAT
IN TERMS OF THE LINEUP THEY HAVE
OUT THERE TONIGHT.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, SHE
APPLAUDED L.A.’S DECISION TO
DEFUND THE POLICE BY
$150 MILLION.
NO PRIVATE -- NO CHOICE.
I THOUGHT LIBERALS WERE
PRO-CHOICE.
NO OPTION FOR YOUR OWN PRIVATE
HEALTH CARE PLAN.
SPONSORING THE GREEN NEW DEAL,
AS I SAID.
OKAY.
NOW JOE SAID IT, POLICE BECOME
THE ENEMY AND HE SUPPORTS
REALLOCATING FUNDS.
OKAY.
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE LACK OF "LAW & ORDER"
AND SAFETY AND SECURITY AND ALL
THESE LIBERAL CITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN RUN BY LIBERAL DEMOCRATS
FOR DECADES.
>> IT’S TRUE.
GO TO FLORIDA, GO TO THE
CAROLINAS, INCREDIBLY SAFE.
GO TO TEXAS, INCREDIBLY SAFE.
YOU GO TO DEMOCRATIC
STRONGHOLDS, GO TO PORTLAND,
SEATTLE, MINNEAPOLIS, CHICAGO
AND NEW YORK CITY AND LOOK AT
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THESE
STATES.
THERE IS ONE COMMON DENOMINATOR
IN ALL THOSE STATES, THEY ARE
RUN BY RADICAL, RADICAL
LEFTISTS.
BOTH MAYORS AND GOVERNORS.
THEIR POLICIES DON’T WORK.
WE’VE SEEN THE CASE STUDIES,
THEY DON’T WORK.
WE DON’T KNOW HOW THIS MOVIE
ENDS.
WE SAW IT OVER THE LAST THREE
MONTHS IN NEW YORK, STRIP OUT
1,000 UNDERCOVER NYPD OFFICERS
IN CRIME GOES UP BY 300%.
THIS ISN’T A DIFFICULT THING TO
FIGURE OUT AND I DON’T KNOW WHY
THEY CONTINUE TO DOUBLE DOWN ON
IT, THIS IS NOT WINNING ISSUE
FOR THEM.
STRIPPING PRIVATE HEALTH CARE IS
NOT A WINNING ISSUE, GETTING RID
OF THE SECOND AMENDMENT ARE NOT
A WINNING ISSUE.
COMING AFTER PEOPLE’S RELIGION,
NOT A WINNING ISSUE.
I DON’T GET IT, I DON’T GET WHY
THIS IS THE POLICY BUT YOU SEE
THE SPEAKERS LINED UP INCLUDING
ELIZABETH WARREN AND I’M SO GLAD
YOU MENTIONED THAT SHE WAS AT
THE NATIVE AMERICAN ROUNDTABLE
YESTERDAY, THESE PEOPLE ARE
TONE-DEAF, THEY REALLY ARE, THEY
DON’T GET THIS COUNTRY, THEY
DON’T GET WHAT AMERICA STANDS
FOR AND THAT’S WHEN MY FATHER IS
GOING TO BEAT THESE GUYS IN 73
DAYS.
>> Sean: 76 BUT WHO’S
COUNTING?